esteemed noble laureates
distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen
it is an honor to participate in the
first nobel prize summit
for 120 years the nobel prize has been
awarded
to the brightest minds in each
generation
in science in literature and in politics
and every nobel prize celebrates one
leap
forward for humanity
take marie curie's radio activity or
emmanuel charpentier's genome editing
it's science at the service of humankind
the pandemic has reminded us how much
we need science in the recent past
some political leaders questioned the
value of science
and the advice of experts for me
as a medical doctor by training it was
painful to watch
so i'm particularly glad for this
opportunity
just to celebrate the noble laureates
contribution
and put renewed trust in science
this year the whole world
has turned towards science to understand
what was happening to us
what was this invisible force that
shattered our lives and our communities
we've turned towards science for advice
and for solutions and science
did deliver in less than 10
months after the beginning of the
pandemic the first vaccines were
approved
if today we have hope
it's thanks to men and women who have
dedicated their entire life to the
laboratory
to a career of hard work and very often
little recognition the world
owes you
and i will not forget how much the
scientific community has helped us
in the toughest moments of this year in
the early days of the crisis
i met regularly up to today with a group
of scientists
chaired by virologist peter peart
working with them reminded me of a
phrase
i first heard when i was a medical
student
in germany it's a quote from
rudolph virgil a 19th century
physician who authored a seminal study
on
epidemics and public health
and virgo said that i quote politics
is nothing else but medicine on a large
scale end of quote and i
can hardly think of a better definition
of everything we've done this year
we have relied on science and we have
tried to put
politics at the service of science and
public health
for instance exactly one year ago europe
contributed to creating the
access to covet tools accelerator the
act accelerator
it works for the worldwide development
of vaccines
therapeutics and diagnostics against
covet 19.
covax is part of this initiative it is
the global facility making vaccines
available and affordable
to all low and middle-income countries
with financing from high-income
countries
science tells us that we must fight the
virus in
all corners of the world and this is the
only effective strategy against the
pandemic
but for this we need international
cooperation
we need politics intended as medicine
on a large scale today
i would like to tell you three reasons
why
and three ways how our governments need
to work with science
the first reason is we need science to
make sense of the world around us
second we need science to guide us
and third we need science to find new
solutions to the challenges of our times
and to fuel innovation for a healthy
planet
so let me begin with the first
science to make sense of the world
the pandemic has already killed almost
three million
people it's hard to fathom
such tragedy and how fragile our human
life can be
but science has warned us for years
scientists have been telling us that
human health
animal health and our planet's health
are one the one health concept
now everyone sees this
with the destruction of forests contacts
between wildlife and humans have
increased
massively because of the loss of
biodiversity
the so-called buffering species are
disappearing
and new pathogens are increasingly
crossing over between animals and humans
we ignored the warnings of sars merce
and ebola so we have to
change course because we have
entered the age of pandemics
during this summit we will hear from
professor johan
rockstrom he is among those who came up
with the idea
of planetary boundaries nine limits
that humanity should not cross
if we don't want to set off irreversible
and devastating consequences
professor rockstrom whose research we
have proudly funded
is now telling us that we have crossed
four
of these nine boundaries so we
must act now before it's too late
and europe is indeed taking action
it is on this basis that we have built
our european green deal
it is because we trust science
that we have committed to cutting by at
least
55 our co2 emissions
already in this decade and
to protecting at least 30 percent
of land and sea here in europe
we now want to broker the same ambition
at global level at the next u.n
biodiversity summit in kunming this
will have to be like cop21 was for
climate a paris-style agreement
for biodiversity and science is helping
us
make sense of a changing world we must
listen to science and europe is
listening
and this leads me to my second point
we need science to guide our daily work
europe is working very closely with the
three international panels
that bring science to the table of
policy makers
ipcc for climate ipbs
for biodiversity and irp
for resources and the circular economy
their advice has been essential
to build an international consensus
around our planet's
state of health it is now time
to find ways for these platforms to work
better together
because everything is connected one
health
one planet one humanity
so we must also join up our work on
climate on biodiversity and on
circularity
for more effective multilateralism
guided by science
my third and final point is that
we need science to innovate and find
solutions
for the challenges of our age
and this means that scientists must have
the resources
they need to do their job think for
instance
about vaccines based on mrna
today it's a multi-billion dollar idea
but that wasn't always the case
back in the 1990s the mother of mrna
vaccines
professor catalin kariko
had a hard time finding money for her
research
she recently recalled and i quote
every night i was working grant grant
grant and it came back always no
no no end of quote
but she never gave up and with time
other researchers joined her fight among
them the biontech team
who could count on several grants from
the european union
our scientists must have the freedom
to explore the frontiers of knowledge
and for this governments must support
pure science and basic research
this is the foundation of human progress
and at the same time it is also vital to
help bring discoveries
from the laboratory to the market
alongside pure science we need
transdisciplinary science connecting
researchers with
business but also with customers and
civil society
and with this in mind we have developed
our new research program
horizon europe it is
the world's largest publicly funded
transnational research and innovation
program
with horizon europe we will also launch
new innovation missions which aim to
transform the way
we live and the way we do business
on this planet we envisage
five missions the first one is beating
cancer
the second one is making europe climate
resilient
the third restoring our oceans and
waters
the fourth 100 climate neutral
cities by 2030. and the fifth
caring for our soils
each of them will tackle a great
challenge of our times
every mission will fund research but it
will also strive
to bring new discoveries to fruition
in a participative approach with
citizens
and last but certainly not least
besides the technological transformation
we need
a cultural transformation too
and for this we need to be much
better at bringing science into every
home
and every community we must invest
in scientific education at all levels
we must help our children understand the
pandemic
how it started and how we can stop it
we must help them understand how our
planet works
and how to save it with climate
education in
every school a widespread
scientific culture is the only antidote
against a mentality that sees
conspiracies
everywhere so yes our democracies
need science and yes
we need a new enlightenment and this
is why this nobel prize summit is such
an important initiative
nobel laureates are humanity's best
and brightest the stalwarts of
scientific culture
we need you to help our kids understand
this complex and beautiful world of
ours we need you on television
on our social media feeds in our homes
a new enlightenment begins there
so thank you to the noble foundation for
your work
and may this nobel prize summit be the
first
in a long series thank you very much for
your attention